hi okay let's see what made the papers
the time 100 was announced today and the
list is diverse
and eclectic and fantastic and i loved
these covers check this out
a shout out to the frontline nurses and
some other heroes also made the list and
comedians influential fingers
figures fingers there's fingers on the
list um
all 10 of them and world leaders and i
just want to thank time for keeping it
classy
and this institution going so check it
out on newsstands fridays i always get
really excited for this
i love the person of the year too okay
this story is so fun and i can't wait to
talk to everyone about it because the
researchers
of the university of kansas say that
they have scientifically determined
how is the most or what is the most
effective flirty face
listen i mean this is important if
anyone wants to flirt out there
they showed men um videos of women
uh making a variety of flirty faces uh
to determine which one sent the clearest
signal
i think this is interesting and i got to
give a shout out to the men working that
day probably not their worst day at
their job
um all right so the results are the
number one most effective flirty look
is head turned to one side
tilted down smile with their eyes
and then like romantic right in there
okay
yes am i doing it
okay well let's let's kick it over to
our vffs who has got a flirty face come
on guys do it with me
all right are you ready yes all right
head down to one side tilt down
i smile
oh you know what oh my god you look so
good you look way better than i do doing
it
uh does anyone have a good flirty
approach are you shannon
yes that's me shannon you are giving it
are you looking for a date cause i think
you're about to get one
i'm actually married well then uh
go straight to your husband because i'm
certainly on his side and um give him
that look
because it's it's effective thank you
well thank you shannon for showing us
the actual
face instead of my goofy one thank you
so much all right
next step when i told the producers and
the writers you know we're all a team
here and we just said like
we need to do things with dads
so we came up with gdp
the good dad program
and we're gonna kick off the signature
series with a dad who founded
dads married to doctors an organization
of fathers married to medical
professionals
please welcome husband and father of
three curtis webster
[Applause]
okay so your organization has reached 4
000 dads in 25 countries tell us about
it
thank you so much for the opportunity it
has been an amazing time
so when we were going through residency
and coming out of upstate new york my
wife and i we had two kids in tow
moving to a brand new place at that
point i was looking around
trying to figure out how to handle all
the new debt the new income
you know at that point we actually had
three kids and i said wow my wife is so
busy working nights and weekends in the
emergency room
she's my she's my hero she's a superhero
saving lives
being on the front lines doing all these
great things for folks she represents
for the family
and here i am in the background
struggling trying to figure out how can
i best live this dmd lifestyle of being
the best husband
father and man and so i figured there
had to be other guys out there that
could help me
figure out how to live this lifestyle
better and that's when dmd was born in
2014.
i have like a cartoon heart just beating
hearts in the eyes
hearts coming out you're just oh please
give a ted talk in a master class
so with three daughters curtis what's
the typical day of dadding look look
oh it's amazing so three young girls
eleven seven and five
and we do everything from trying to stay
healthy and fit especially sitting
behind the computers all day
cooking we'll be painting nails i don't
have a painted right now but we'll be
painting nails
we'll be going out on walks just doing
everything we can to immerse
real life with education and make every
every day a learning moment
my wife and i agreed early on we wanted
to establish anchor points
so let's have a ton of fun but let's
also make sure we're integrating work
and real life responsibility so that we
can learn how to balance
all those different aspects so it's it's
so much fun it's a crazy life
curtis i mean when we talked about
kicking this program off of gdp
never in our wildest dreams would we
think we'd meet someone
who would elevate it to the level that
you have i can't thank you enough
will you please come back and help us
give suggestions for a thing we do
called the weekender because i'm always
looking for things to do
with my kids and that's sort of what
gave me the idea for this i wanted to
celebrate dads and also it's as parents
we're always looking for like
new ideas so let's keep doing this
you are our hero and if you have a dad
that you want to shine a light on go to
our website
for the gdp good dads program curtis
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
oh my god and
finally our next story may upset you if
you are over the age of 30.
because the 1980s now count as ancient
history
american girl has just added a 80s doll
to their historical collection and we
have her here today
in the studio please welcome courtney
oh my god courtney it says you hail from
the dinosaur age of 1986.
look at your cool high-waisted denim
skirt and pink scrunchie you know that's
going to end up on the cover of bop
magazine next month
by the way i don't even need to do an
accent let's face it i'm stuck with this
valley girl accent for life i was born
in california in the 1980s in the 818
area code and
i don't have to fake it all right i love
your 80s accessories and bangles lip
smacker and lip balm
a see-through phone so choice again
totally my voice
this is just me not playing it up no
hyper ball
you even have a caboodle for your hair
ties and makeup and other trinkets
righteous to the max by the way in your
future courtney when you have to talk to
a high-powered ceo
and you're like no really bet on me
invest i
got you it's gonna be great
listen courtney i really think we could
have been friends
i mean here's a pic of me around your
age i was
all up in the club that night a term
you'll learn in about a decade and a
half
but for now let's just say that
you're stuck with this voice for life
and you know what
it's not so bad all right court i'm
sorry we're out of time i didn't let you
get a word in edgewise you gotta come
back all right
come back yes okay
[Music]